hi i'm farzan and
today i'm going to talk about the
metrical task systems problem on general
metric spaces
this is based on a joint work with james
lee
so first let me define the problem uh
so imagine we're given a metric space in
this case the path matrix and that we
are standing at the point in this
measure
now at any point in time a monster
appears at some point in this metric
and if it appears that somewhere that
you're standing on you have to make a
move
either to the left or to the right here
and if it appears that somewhere that
you're not standing on you don't have to
take any actions
and uh we have to make these decisions
online we don't know
what will happen in the future
and we will be paying a total cost of
the amount of
distance that we have traveled over time
and the goal is to
minimize
the cost of this online algorithm when
compared to an optimal offline algorithm
that knows the future
so more precisely we say that an online
algorithm uh is alpha competitive if for
any fixed sequence fixed input sequence
uh
until any
time t
the cost paid by the algorithm is at
most alpha times
the cost of the opt
uh
here we allow some constant additive
factor and this
factor can depend on the metric but the
crucial thing is that it cannot depend
on uh
it cannot grow with t
and uh
it's not hard to
verify that
if we are only allowed to
make actions deterministically we can't
hope to get a competitive ratio better
than omega n
but
if if randomness is allowed we can do
much better so what do i mean by that so
suppose
we allow the algorithm to
take random actions
and then we're measuring the cost of the
algorithm as the expected cost that is
going to pay
and if we do that
we can do much better we can get down to
poly logarithmic factors
where n here is the number of points of
the metric space
so more generally the magical task
systems problem is defined as follows
you're given a
metric space x
and a
a sequence of cost vectors non-negative
cost vectors ct arrive over time
and we have to respond to ct
online
with a
possibly random point xt and x
and the total cost that you're going to
pay is the is the sum of a service cost
and a movement cost
the service class is the
entry of this class vector at the point
xt
and uh that you're playing on and the
movement cost would be the distance that
we have traveled as we saw in the
earlier example
and the cost of our algorithm would of
course be the expected value of uh this
quantity
equivalently we can view this problem as
one in which
we are allowing the algorithm to play a
point in the probability simplex on x
so more precisely suppose that
the algorithm is playing
at a point mu t
in
kx where kx is the probability simplex
defined on x
and then
the service cost
the expected service class would be
exactly the inner product of ct and mu t
and the movement cost can be described
as uh
this earth mover distance between mu t
minus one and mu t
and
and so
one other way to view this is that we
are allowing the algorithm to pla play a
fractional mass on different points in
this metric
yeah so this problem was defined was
introduced in 1992
by boarding linear
and sex
and it is one of the
central
problems in the area of online
algorithms
and it has been conjectured that
the correct bound the correct
competitive bound for this problem is
uh theta of login
and in fact uh
for certain metric spaces
it has been proven that we can
either do
for the login competitive or like
an omega login
bound is necessary
but for general metric spaces the best
thing that we know after long sequence
of work is log squared of n
and as an upper bound and the best lower
bound that we know is log n over log log
n
our focus on this stack would be
on the side of upper bounds and
so now let me tell you how this upper
bound of log n squared is
uh achieved in this on this problem
so let's first look at
a rather simple example of the
uniformity
and so uniform metric is a metric on
endpoints in which the distance of any
two points is exactly the same say one
and
the first heuristic that comes into mind
is that
given a class vector
what should probably do is to
reduce the mass at point i proportional
to
the amount of cost that
point the point i sees so if some point
is more cost it makes sense to reduce
the mass
uh faster there
so
so yeah maybe
the first algorithm that comes into mind
is
say define this mu t plus one as mu t
minus some eta times c
where eta
is a
learning rate
and uh
of course there's this issue that we're
only decreasing mass here and we would
be leaving the
probability simplex if you just did that
so instead we have to
project this point back
into the probabilities in place or in
other words we have to somehow
redistribute this remote mass to the
other points
and
and yeah
the first guess might be to do
to this projection just based on the
euclidean distance
and if you do that then the algorithm
sort of corresponds to the project that
gradient descent
now that in the
gradient descent we are moving by this
uh
by the gradient instead of this vector c
but other than that these algorithms are
the same
and uh
but that unfortunately doesn't work what
we can do something
that is kind of a generalization of this
uh given a strictly convex function phi
we define is
bregman divergence
uh
of two points based on phi
as is phi of mu minus five nu
minus the gradient
at mu times nu minus mu
and this is always a non-negative
quantity uh
and it follows from convexity of phi
and uh
and yeah if if we do this projection
based on this fragment divergence
then what we have is a mere decent
algorithm
and uh
and the nice thing about it is that
this mirror descent
provides us with a
with a sort of uh
the mere decent framework sort of
provides us with a potential function
that lets us control the
progress of the algorithm
so more precisely
uh
if we do this step with this uh
bregman divergence as described well
then for any point me nu star
uh
this inequality holds and what this is
telling us is that
if uh
our algorithms stays at mu t
or mu t plus 1 pays more cost than nu nu
star
then
it would get closer
to nu star in terms of the breakdown
divergence
so so the the algorithm cannot get uh
cannot pay more more more service costs
than opt uh
forever
and
if there are some certain
lipiousness con
and under some
mild richness conditions
uh
this would allow us to bound the service
cost of the algorithm
by the total cost that the optimal
algorithm is paying
and uh in fact this is something very
uh
crucial here because
in the earlier work
on
online algorithms and in particular in
the magical test systems program one of
the hardest parts of the analysis was to
be able to relate to
somehow analyze the
behavior of the optimal algorithm to be
able to relate
the cost of your algorithm to the
customers but
here uh essentially for a large family
of
regularizers phi
uh
you would automatically have
this uh
property that your algorithm
is competitive in terms of its service
cost
so so the service cost of your algorithm
would be a proxy for
the cost of all
and if you can also bound your movement
class by your own service cost
then you would be down
so
now the whole problem gets down to
choosing this the correct regularizer
phi
so
if it took phi to be
five mutually just the normal squared of
mu
then what you would end up with was is
the same as
the project that gradient sends
and then
the
the update formula would be given by
something like this
here lambda i would correspond to the
logarithms multipliers that are
essentially keeping you inside the
particle but let's forget about these
terms
for the sake of this talk
and
so your update would be
approximately
minus eta times
ci of t
and the issue here is that there is no
way that we can relate this value to the
cost that the algorithm is paying
and
and so that is our only proxy for
the cost of art
but if we do something more clever
and take
phi to be the negative of the
channel entropy
a mu
which is the sum of mi like mu i
then the breakman divergence
would turn out to be
the relative entropy
and the update will look like this
and
if we ignore the term lambda
you can see that
the amount of mass that is moving at
point miui is
approximately mu i times c i
which is exactly the
amount of service cost that you're
paying at point c i at point i
so
so we are moving
with the same amount of mass that we are
we
are moving the same amount of mass as to
what we are paying at the cost
and
that is
very very convenient
and this is very good then we would be
able to
found our movement cost
by
some factor of
the service class
and we already know this is bounded by
the service cost of the art so we're in
good shape
but
this regularizer doesn't work yet
it's because as i mentioned earlier you
also need some
liciousness assumptions and phi to each
row as well
which is not true in this case and for
that there is
a fix which is
instead of working with the entropy
itself we have to work with this shifted
entropy
we shift
all the values by some delta
uh where delta is
1 over n
in here
and
our update rules would change and the
analysis will become a bit more
complicated but at the end of the day we
can show that
this algorithm is long and competitive
now if we were
instead working with a more general
problem
which is
now suppose
instead of working with the uniform
metric we're
uh looking at this problem on the way to
the star
which is
so the metric is defined as the shortest
path past distance between
uh the leaves of the weight of the star
so the distance between like this vertex
v2
and v3 is defined as w2 plus w3
this is the shortest platform
and
it turns out that with
some minor modification
to this regularizer
we could still get a login competitive
algorithm and what we should do is we
should
weight this entropy
by w i so we should wait the term
corresponding to mu i by wi
and what this would do
is that it would slow
slow down the updates of mu i
by a factor of 1 over wi which kind of
makes sense because if the weight of
some edge is large you don't want to
change that edge
fast because otherwise you would be
paying
a lot of movement class
and this algorithm is still logging
competitive uh
now let's move to a
more general family of metric spaces uh
that are called hierarchically separated
trees or hscs
so an hsc is basically
a rooted
weighted tree
in which the weight of the edges goes
down geometrically along root leaf paths
and then the metric is defined on a set
of leaves of this
tree
uh
it can be defined as the shortest path
distance between
those pair of pairs of vertices
and uh
and you can see that as the weights go
down geometrically here
the length of the shortest pass is
essentially dominated by the largest
weight of an edge
in this
path and the interesting fact about hscs
is that they can
approximate any metric uh up to a factor
of log n
so what does that mean it means that uh
we can
randomly embed
any given metric into an hst
so that
the distances
do not go down at all and in expectation
they only go up by a factor of volume
an implication of this theorem is that
if we can find
an order alpha competitive algorithm for
hsts
we would then obtain a
an order alpha times log n competitive
algorithm for any metric
by just using a black box reduction this
year
and in fact this is how
uh
we do have a bound for general matrix in
the pre prior work
uh
in the work of bubba cos boba cohen
e
and they will curve coaster and d
what they actually do is that they
provide an order log in competitive
algorithm
for hst matrix
and then
use this theorem to show that
any metric uh for any matrix you would
have an ordered login squared
competitive algorithm
so perhaps not surprisingly
they
they obtain this login factor
using a mere decent algorithm
so
instead of directly working uh on the
probability simplex defined on the
points of metric symmetric space which
in this case
are just the leaves of this hst
they work with a lift of this
simplex
so more precisely they
represent
the probability distribution only on the
leaves as
a unit flow from the root of this tree
to its leaves
so so first
the root gets to decide
how much
mass is going to play on the left
subtree and how much on the right
subtree
and then the nodes at the second layer
get inside how much of the incoming mass
are they gonna play
on the left and right subtrees and so on
so
it's a step-by-step decisions and
decision making process
sort of
and uh
and then given these internal variables
f which
represent the flow
if we define this regularizer as follows
it turns out that we would obtain a
login competitive algorithm
on these hst metrics
so to make sense of this regularizer uh
maybe let's first forget about these
delta values
and uh
and also rearrange the terms
so
what you would get
is essentially
a weighted sum of
of so if you look at this thing this
looks very similar to
what we had for the case of the weighted
star
so
essentially this algorithm is running
weight as a star on each of these
internal nodes
kind of separately
but uh
but what the variable that is running
this on is uh
these ratios f u v over f u i forgot to
tell so this fu
is the incoming flow to you
flow
to you
so
so since this is a tree
uh
incoming flow so the flow just comes
from the pattern of that node so the
incoming flow to
uh this node is exactly f12 to this node
is exactly
f
511 and so
on and so this ratio
some sort of uh
is the
conditional probability
of playing on the subject with that v
given that we are playing at
the sub 3 rooted at u
and uh
and then
the dynamics would look like something
like this and
which is also very similar to what we
had
in the case of weighted star but now
our variables are these ratios
as i alluded to earlier uh
so the way
this
prior work uh handle the case of general
matrix is just via a simple black box
reduction to
these hsc measures
and
and then
you would get a login squared
bound but the conjecture is that we
should be able to do login on elementary
and this extra factor of login that
comes from this black box reduction
seems kind of unnecessary
so
uh
it seems like mere descent is the
correct
framework to approach this problem
and
as a first step towards getting rid of
that login factor
one might ask whether at least we can
get rid of this black black reduction
and directly do mere descent
and some polytope that is related to our
metric and get a
competitive algorithm that is
log n squared combination
or even like polylogging competitive and
in fact this was asked by uberx
and our main result is that we answer
this question positively
and we show that
essentially we get the
same
competitiveness guarantees
we are
running it
purely running a mere descent algorithm
on a dag that is built on top of the
given metric x
so what do i mean by that uh i'll
explain that
in a minute
so first let's look at the path metric
again
uh
suppose we wanna embed it into
this ssc
where uh
the weight of the edges at this bottom
layer is one
at the top layer is two
and four
and eight and so on
and we can see that although in this
hsc the distance of for instance
these two vertices is well preserved
uh
i mean it's two in this hst metric and
it's one in the original originality
but uh on the other hand the distance
between a pair of vertices like these
two
in the middle
is not well preserved at all it's like
two to the
uh height of the tree which is uh
n
where n is the number of
nodes here
and
and so the approximation
is far from being correct in the hst
so uh
and we wanted to be like off by a
logarithmic factor at first
so if for instance the adversary made
you
move a lot of times between these two
points
by simulating the
mirror dynamics on this hsc you wouldn't
get a competitive algorithm because
yet the
because the hsc has a very bad estimate
of the correct distance between these
two
and uh
so this is why we would need to
do this hst embedding randomly and we
cannot just
embed this path metric into a fixed hst
so
here is how we fix it
in our results
so we still consider the same kind of
dynamics that represents uh know that
the leaf by flow
from the root to the leaves
uh
and
and like the distribution is determined
by by these flows
but uh we kind of modified this tree and
add some new edges to it
and so that it wouldn't be a tree
anymore but it will still be a dag
and uh
and now there are multiple ways that to
send a flow to
any leaf industry for instance if you
take
this reference
uh for instance
we can send it like this
like that
uh
sorry
like that
uh
like that
or
from this path
perhaps so there are multiple ways to
represent a single
vertex in this uh a single leaf in this
uh
dag
uh
and eventually what we're gonna play is
at this
leaf is the sum over all these uh
some of our all incoming flows to
display from any
path from the source
what we do next is we
define this
regularizer which is
similar to the previous one
a multi-scale
entropic regularizer
[Music]
and uh
we can define it in the same way the
only difference is that here
if
uh
so previously fu was defined as the
incoming flow which was determined by
the flow from the parent to a node and
it is a still the case for a node like
this one which has only one incoming
edge
but for instance this income this node
has two edges going into it so f of this
node would be the sum of this f36 and
f26
uh
adding these cross edges would allow us
to uh
somehow be able to incorporate all
reasonable hsc embeddings into this tag
within
while
like paying a constant factor
approximation
so for instance
to see that the issue that we had
earlier doesn't
persist anymore
[Music]
so the issue was uh
for moving a lot between these two nodes
and uh
so if we were representing the flow to
the node on the left by this path
then we could simply
change it change it to a flow to the
node on the right by
deleting the
mass on this edge and adding it into
the this edge on the right and both of
these edges are of weight one so
so the total amount of weight that we
are changing here is proportional to the
actual distance between these two notes
so
so yeah then
the dynamics on this tag will also be
defined similarly
to the previous one and what we can show
is that uh
this dynamics is logging and squared
competitive in this metric now that is
not login competitive as it was for the
case of adjustments
so what's the reason
the reason is that by
building this stack
we still play a
login factor
in terms of the approximation
uh
roughly speaking what happens is that
although this tag contains all the
necessary
all the like
important hsc embeddings
uh for this method
in order for the algorithm to move
between to switch between these
representations
it will still need to pay a lot of cost
and that is
not something that we can bound nicely
and the
main technical contribution in our paper
is to show that uh
for any metric constructing such a dag
is possible
uh for the case of the path metric
uh it's it's an easy exercise maybe
but in general it's
much more complicated
and then we show that as long as uh
the number of sourcing paths in this lag
is bounded is polynomially bounded
the number of points in the metric
then uh
the algorithm the dynamics is log and
compact competitive
and by putting these two things together
we would obtain that
this dynamics and the dag is logging
squared competitive with respect to the
original metric
and just to see that
this was the case for
this tag
note that uh
the out the out degree of uh
every node was at most four here
there are four edges going out
and the height of the tree is around log
n so there are almost four to the log
and many uh sourcing capacity here
which is polynomial
and
that's it
and as for the open problems uh
so of course uh we do not improve
upon this login squared bound although
we have made some conceptual progress in
this problem
and uh
even for the path metric we can't do
better than
log n squared
we don't know how to do that
and as for the lower bound in general
this is still open to improve up and
this log in our log log in
and
it is well known that if you can prove a
bound for hst matrix it would employ a
lower bond for all metrics